you may know Juggalos already there the
fans of detroit horrorcore rap group
insane clown posse and you're about to
find out why they may be one of the best
representations of a self-reliant and
yet demonized community
Juggalos garnered a lot of mainstream
attention in 2011 when the FBI
classified them as a group that could
exhibit gang-like behavior and engage in
criminal activity and violence
reclassify their [ __ ] cuz I don't do
nothing violent I smoke weed and I
listen to music
yeah well rough eachother up a little
bit put each other back in line but I
mean we're not gonna harm anyone unless
someone does harm unto us Juggalos we
talked to at the 2013 gathering of the
Juggalos disputed the claims made by the
FBI the event is an annual music
festival held in the sleepy town of Cave
and Rock Illinois it's a bunch of kids
running around girls topless drinking
soda doing drugs yelling boo boo kamil
Todaro is a journalist who has written
for Gawker and The Village Voice about
insane clown posse and Juggalos it's
become an identity for a lot of kids who
happen to be attracted to the music
it's a term much like you know a Beiber
believer or deadhead or you know fish
head but unlike those fans Juggalos
carried the game classification a label
that could be used by federal and local
law enforcement to subject Juggalos to
routine stops
detainment and interrogation I see P
Shaggy 2 dope and violent J agree and
are suing the FBI along with the
American Civil Liberties Union of
Michigan claiming the profiling Juggalos
as a gang violates their constitutional
right to express themselves I think it's
ridiculous to consider the Juggalos gang
though Darrow says Juggalos are among
the most misunderstood people of all
time in some ways it's almost ironic in
the sense that these are a group of
people who no one else in Amer
has ever cared about and then this one
man gave them a sense of identity so it
was almost like a support group a whole
train of it man all train well drug
loads are from a lower-class often what
all obviously and some of those kids are
committing crimes that's part of who I
CPS has been reaching though is people
who are really bad upbringing so you
know they had weed on them or those kids
already
you know we're gonna rob somebody and it
just so happens that they happen to like
also be a Juggalo marijuana marijuana
come and get you marijuana from me from
me and that's not to say that there are
even that many kids doing it it's just
that it just so happened that somebody
caught on to the fact that oh those kids
who have that hatchet man sometimes
steal things but if they didn't have
that hatchet on they're stealing things
anyway like it doesn't matter you know
these things are not at all affiliated
whatsoever they became drug laws because
they were persecuted and now they're
being persecuted for bonding together
because they were persecuted that
bonding is something that was passed
down from the members of Insane Clown
Posse who grew up in lower-class
households just like their fans they
were the you know the outcasts in school
but not even the outcasts like the
freaks where you would think about you
know artists or like brood brooders or
gay people they were like scrubs there
are like dirty kids they were the slow
kids they were the uneducated like the
ones who just you know the home lives
are so bad that they couldn't even make
it to school then typically you know
don't end up being very successful but
they rebelled against that against that
perception and decided they were gonna
be rappers and it worked really really
really hard and part of the clown makeup
was because they realize how ridiculous
they were and they've managed to like
attract a whole group of fans that
nobody else had ever spoken to or
reached out to in music there's a lot of
people that don't want you to live your
life how you want to live it you know
there's a lot of people that that don't
agree with what you're doing and they
want to try to stop you from just having
fun and you know just being yourself and
being free
here you can actually like get away with
it one of the things is insane clown
posse has done that nobody else has ever
done in the music industry or even in
the cultural interest industry in my
mind is it our gated victims not goth
victims but it but targeted kids who
were molested kids were you know
basically like the people who worked at
gas stations like I said those are
Insane Clown Posse's people I work a
hard [ __ ] job every [ __ ] day what
do you do I [ __ ] you ever heard of a
full-service gas station I'm [ __ ] out
there in the hot Sun every [ __ ] day
just [ __ ] pumping gas running around
handling money there's a lot of people
that grow up by yourself you know single
mothers or homeless or whatnot this is a
place to to connect and meet and
actually feel loved man yes and make
friends and relate with people the
result is a world where these young
people have escaped the life they were
dealt for community that they helped to
create this is family right here this is
love right here peace it's family it's
all about family it's all love here
because there is a you know unity of
exclusion outside in the world being
among Juggalos feels like one really
safe place and so it feels like kind of
a family where you know these people
will have your back no matter what
nobody else gets you the way that these
other people do and because there is
that sense of family Juggalos look out
for one another like siblings would I've
been trying to keep you guys safe the
entire time they've been here drink
water put sunblock on just everything
for mine if you're at the gathering and
you're amongst other Juggalos you can
ask for water you can ask for anything
and it will be immediately given to you
because you remember the family and like
any community they have their own
language Juggalos champ it's a it's a
like hello it's an expression of love
and expression of acceptance it sounds
kind of like a like a flock of like
horny owls
whoa whoa see that's what it's about
they even have their own beverage the
inexpensive soda pop Faygo violent Jay
who's insane clown posse is two members
who's growing up you know they go was
always in the pantry so it became part
of kind of like being a poor scrubby
kids identity you know it was a cheapest
soda and in Detroit or in Michigan got
them three leaders right on Michigan a
dollar fifty come here and have them
nice Faygo showers but the most critical
part of the Juggalo community or its
leaders Jumbos feel like ICP violently
and Shaggy 2 dope love them love them
you know even if they don't know them
specifically what they have given them
in terms of you know fun and belonging
and sense of ownership is very much like
a familial like parental kind of love I
mean you kind of go back to the real
world and you just kind of wonder why is
everyone so mean to each other it's not
necessary there's too much I've never
understood that violence whoa what's the
dog with having just one common interest
the FBI said it couldn't comment on
pending litigation but the effects of
the gang label may have already impacted
the next gathering of the Juggalos the
2014 music festival had to change
locations multiple times thanks in part
to the fears of local residents fierce
insane clown posse says are associated
with the gang classification for recent
TV i'm paul dietrich
[Music]